finie la sieste l'opposition monte en
ligne l'opposition à l'abordage voilà
les titres que l'on trouve aujourd'hui
dans libération le figaro et le matin
pour évoquer le grand feuilleton de
l'été
je veux dire la sphère greenpeace alors
que depuis le début de cette affaire la
droite l'opposition avait observé une
réserve prudente
voilà qu'à l'occasion du débat au sénat
sur la nouvelle calédonie elle lance ses
premières salves par la voix de charles
pasqua pour le rpr et de jean lecanuet
pour l'udf
le premier demande rien moins que la
démission de laurent fabius
le deuxième se contenterait de celle de
charles hernu et accuse le pouvoir
socialiste de vouloir faire retomber la
faute sur les lampistes
si comme je le crains et comme je le
crois
ce gouvernement est incapable d'assumer
ses responsabilités alors le moment est
venu de dire à monsieur laurent fabius
de sanaa les quelle différence cela fort
at-il quelle différence cela fera t-il
il n'est pas là aujourd'hui
il n'est jamais là lorsqu'un texte
important où l'intérêt national de
l'église
oui oui oui
oui oui oui il y a longtemps que
monsieur fabius a atteint son niveau
d'incompétence qu'il démissionne c'est
le seul service qu'ils puissent encore
rendre à la république
premières réactions à gauche celle de
monsieur labarrère